[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARISHMAH SHAH: So ladies, thank
you so much for being here.
I'm excited to host this panel.
You're going to hear from
some wonderful women.
They'll share some
lessons with you
that they've learned across
some incredible journeys.
And then we'll leave you with
a little bit of fun, too.
So let's get started.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourselves?
We'll just go down the line.
And in addition to telling us
a little bit about your story,
tell us your proudest
accomplishment in the past 12
months.
KATY EXLINE: Sure.
So my name is Katy Exline.
And just to clarify, I'm
a developer at Braintree.
But thank you for the
promotion to director.
I'm a back-end
developer at Braintree,
but I am also the
co-leader of Girl
Develop It here in Chicago.
My background is not
in computer science.
I used to be a policy
researcher at a think tank
that studied tech and
manufacturing policy.
And I had a really
terrible spreadsheet
that I had to work with every
day, as I'm sure many of us
have encountered in our life.
And I thought, man, I could
really use a database.
I don't know how to make
one, but that sounds right.
So I did some furious googling,
and I came across a Girl
Develop It class in Columbus,
Ohio where I'm from.
And so I took it on a whim.
And it was intro
to HTML and CSS,
which isn't databases,
but close enough.
It was something technical.
I thought it was close enough.
And I had just an
amazing experience.
It was a woman teacher
who was also a developer.
And it was an experience where
I raised my hand in the class
and said, can you tell
me what a server is?
I hear people talk about them,
but I don't totally understand.
And rather than snickering
at me or giving me
the eye like, oh gosh,
not one of these,
she explained it to me with
so much empathy and love.
And so I got into this group
of women in Girl Develop It,
and it just kind of
snowballed from there.
So I ended up attending
a coding bootcamp here,
called Dev Bootcamp, in Chicago.
And then I worked as another
developer at a company
called Fooda.
And then from there, I am
now a back-end developer
at Braintree, so just a
whirlwind of snowballing
one position after another.
But that's my story.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Amazing.
What's your proudest
accomplishment
in the past 12 months?
KATY EXLINE: So there's just
so many amazing women here
who have these really
great accomplishments,
and my biggest accomplishment
is I racked a server.
So going back full circle, I did
a rotation on our platform team
this year, and I
actually took a-- we call
them piggies, but popped
some more RAM in there,
and then racked it and
wired up all the networks.
And it was just like, I can't
believe three years later I'm
doing this thing that was
such a black box to me
a couple years ago.
That's my proudest
accomplishment.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Amazing, that's
still a black box for me.
BRENDA WILKERSON: Hi,
I'm Brenda Wilkerson.
I started out as a computer
science major accidentally.
I was pre-med.
And at my university
you had to choose
some sort of major
that satisfied all
of the that and something else.
And so I chose
biomedical engineering.
And the lucky thing for
me was that all engineers
had to take a couple
programming classes.
So that's how I even found
out about computer science.
And after much wracking of
brain and changing of mind,
I changed to computer
science as a major
and actually worked in software
engineering for half my career.
Very exciting work--
working for Fortune
500 companies, doing a
bunch of programming.
I got into education sort
of accidentally as well.
I was wearing that beeper
and up half the night
fixing problems
with whatever system
that I was responsible for.
And my husband and I were
pregnant with our first child.
And I thought, I'm going to be
up taking care of that baby.
I don't want to be up taking
care of this software.
So what else can I do?
And luckily, we met a friend who
was dean of a community college
who kept asking me, what
else do you want to do?
And I ended up being
an adjunct professor
there, teaching other people who
wanted to career change and get
into technology, to be sort
of that conduit for people
who never thought that
they could but wanted
to take a shot at it.
And I did that for years.
And at the same time
I was raising my kids,
doing software development,
consulting on the side.
I was sharing with
a colleague here
about how in the
middle of the night
I'd be nursing my baby,
clicking before sending off
the software to my client.
So yes, if you're in that
space, you can do it too.
And then I got into my
current position a little bit
later on when the
opportunity presented itself
to sort of shepherd
Chicago public schools
from what they were
then calling IT
education to real IT education.
It was about Microsoft Word
at the time-- really exciting
to be able to be right at
that point in our history
where the whole awareness around
computer science education
has increased.
Most recently, I would say
the most exciting thing
I've gotten to do is to
bring computer science
core in Chicago public schools.
We now have a
graduation requirement.
[APPLAUSE]
Very exciting.
We have kindergartners talking
about their algorithms.
And then we had the White
House steal our name.
We now have National
Computer Science
For All, which is very exciting.
And I get to be
part of that group
to sort of shepherd
that conversation
across the country.
So it's a really great time
to be a nerd, so come on.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Amazing,
and we'll hear more
about that from Brenda soon.
You may have switched
from medicine,
but I guess you can't get
away from being on call, huh?
BRENDA WILKERSON:
No, that's right.
Good one.
RIANA LYNN: Hi everyone,
my name is Riana Lynn.
I'm the founder of Food Trace.
Also, as was
mentioned earlier, I
serve under Google
Ventures Google
for Entrepreneurs wing at
Google as an entrepreneur
in residence.
So a lot of people
ask me what that is.
Maybe I can get into that later.
But I would have to say that
my track began pretty early.
I was always interested in
impacting our health and food
systems from a very young age.
I ended up going to college to
study biology and chemistry,
and had a computer science
major within my dorm room.
Before I registered
for any classes,
my university was one
of the first schools
allowed to be on Facebook.
And so I actually registered
for Facebook before any classes
when Facebook came
out that year in 2004,
and became very interested
in building websites.
All of my buddies were
just young white men
that were building the
sites at that point in time.
I wanted to build websites for
businesses and for business
owners that I was meeting
just because I've always
been entrepreneurial.
And so I learned how to build
websites and content manager
systems in my dorm room.
Outside of just doing
tracking and studying biology,
I thought that I was going to
go into a lab, and work in labs,
and maybe travel throughout
the world finding
different problems to solve.
But by the time I got
to graduate school,
I felt very limited in that,
and approached a family member,
and wanted to start my first
venture into entrepreneurship,
and ended up launching a chain
of juice bars here in Chicago.
And within that
endeavor, I really
learned how impactful e-commerce
would be on our food system,
and built a side that
allowed us to have
people purchase juice
and products from all
over the world.
And I ended up meeting
business owners
that were inspired
by that story,
and asked me to help them
build out their e-commerce
and their supply chains
for their food businesses.
And soon after I turned that
into a kind of consulting
house.
And within a few months,
that was acquired,
and I started working
for national food
companies purchased under the
CNBC show called "The Profit."
I don't know if you
guys watched that.
But I worked very closely
with Marcus Lemonis,
who is the host of that, comes
on right after "Shark Tank."
So I had a really exciting time
building websites and logistics
systems for shows that were
going to come on in two weeks.
So they would come to
me and say, we just
bought this company.
Launch a new website, give
them all this e-commerce,
and their sales are going to
go up from probably $400 a day
to over $20,000 in
purchases per day.
And so it's really exciting
being part of that experience.
But I realized that a lot
of these food companies
had a lot of supply
chain issues.
And no matter how
much marketing they
got, how good their
product was, they
were still going to have lots
of operational issues, lots
of loss of money within
their supply chain.
And that's when I decided
to fully launch Food Trace.
And at that time, it really
became empowering to me
to know that the
industries that I think
are the oldest and most
impactful in the world-- that
being agriculture and
technology-- I could finally
use what I was originally
passionate about as a young
kid, and technology,
which I became very
passionate about in
college, and turn that
into a software company.
And so it's been very exciting
over the last couple of years
developing that, to
also be a young minority
woman working in two industries
that are very heavily male
dominated.
The average tech leader
and the average farmer
do not look much like me,
and so inspiring women
to go into both of
those industries
and be a very impactful
I would say probably
rolls into what has been,
especially over the past 12
months, something that
has been one of my biggest
accomplishments.
Being at the forefront of
"Forbes" and "Ag Tech,"
but also inspiring
young women in tech
at the same time
over the past year
has been something that I
really value and look to develop
over the coming years as well.
So happy to be here.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: Hi.
I'm Justine Rembisz, and I work
at X as a mechanical engineer.
I got really lucky
at a young age
in that I went to magnet
school for math and science
in high school.
And I got to take what
I call all the -ics,
so robotics,
electronics, photonics.
And I fell in love with
robotics when I was there.
So I knew that that is
what I wanted to do.
So I went to Carnegie
Mellon, which
had one of the best robotics
programs in the country,
and decided that mechanical
engineering was my path there.
I know nothing
about software, so I
think I'm one of the few
people here in that realm.
After graduating there, I
went and worked for iRobot
and did research for them.
So this was soft
robotics, five to 10 year
outward looking stuff.
How do we get something
to squish under a door
and then keep moving?
After that, I moved
to a company called
4moms, which was completely
opposite end of the industry
scale, where I was doing
mass manufacturing for baby
products.
So these were like strollers
that fold themselves,
or baby seats that use
electromechanical motion
to soothe the babies
that are sitting in them.
Again, worked there
for about three years,
and then I joined a startup
out in San Francisco
called Redwood
Robotics that were
doing low cost industrial arms.
And so that, again, was
kind of somewhere different
in the industry.
And we got bought by Google
six months after I joined,
and so that's how I came to X.
I would say a theme
throughout my career
is that women are not
very present, especially
in the hardware
side of industry.
It was six years into
my career before I
had a meeting with
another woman in it
in a tech capacity,
which is horrible.
And so I've been doing
a lot during my career
to try to change that.
When I was at
4moms in Pittsburgh
I started a robotics
workshop for young kids.
Personally, I feel
like middle school age
is about the age where
women start hearing, no, you
can't do this.
Don't go on to math and science.
That's more of a boy thing.
It starts to get hard.
So I really wanted
to tackle that area.
And what I'm proud about
in the last 12 months
is that I'm starting
that program with X here,
and I'm working specifically
with underprivileged schools
in the Mountain View area.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Amazing.
Justine's other
proudest accomplishment
in the past 12 months
after this panel
might be converting some
of you to roboticists.
NICOLE YEARY: Hello, everybody.
First of all, I want to
thank Google Women Techmakers
for inviting me here today.
It's really a pleasure to be
among so many incredible women
in one room.
My name is Nicole Yeary.
I'm the founder of Ms. Tech.
We help business women with tech
and tech women with business.
And really what that
means is that early,
early on, I discovered
some challenges
around venture
capital in wanting
to build a health website
and needing a HIPAA
certified developer.
My journey through
this was really,
I started out wanting
to be a nurse,
because I thought they
just helped people.
And then I found
out, you know, blood
and all that sort of thing.
So I pursued first
being an attorney,
and then eventually
ended up going
into architectural
engineering at Purdue.
But like you, in AutoCAD
classes, I was the only woman.
That was OK with me, though.
I didn't really have a
big problem with that.
I eventually rolled
into insurance.
Don't ask me how that happened.
And I loved my job.
And then in 2009 I was cut,
just like a lot of other people,
and found myself with a degree
of various different learnings
and skill sets in sales and
marketing and very soft skills,
but nothing that was really
applicable to the world
that we had kind of
evolved into this Web 2.0.
And yet I wanted
to continue working
on solving some problems
around health insurance.
And as I mentioned
earlier, I found out
I needed a HIPAA
certified developer.
If I had to do it over again,
I would have just built it
and not did that.
But to raise capital, I
didn't have the opportunity
to really get a
meeting with a VC.
I didn't know how that worked.
I didn't have the network.
I ended up working for another
startup called Sprout Socials.
Some of you may
have heard of that.
I was their first hire.
And after 90 days in
watching Justin build,
I was like, if he can
do it, I can do it.
So I started to go out there.
And it was really, really hard.
And I started a Facebook
group with other women that
were like myself-- very
smart and laid off of work,
and building
WordPress sites, doing
whatever they could to
hustle to make money,
because there were no jobs.
We eventually started
to have brunch together
and realized that, well,
if you're better at design,
then I'll do the SEO, and
you can put everything
on the back-end server.
And we'll just work together
and hire each other.
This Facebook group
started with eight women,
and it just blew up.
We continued to
only invite women
that were like ourselves,
who were really
serious about
helping one another,
and seeing women in tech really
grow and foster community.
And I eventually ran out of
money and went back to Ohio,
and realized that there was
an opportunity for me to focus
what I saw myself
making the biggest
impact in my life, which was,
here's this group of women,
and what am I doing just
as a Facebook group?
We could do so much more.
If I was struggling
with venture capital,
why don't I go focus
on changing that?
So we created a second
layer of Ms. Tech.
And it's a first
class membership
where we believe women invest
in themselves-- $35 a month
so that we could create a
sustainability for this group
and actually create some
research that hasn't been done.
We don't know how many women
are going out there and pitching
VCs, how many are
actually getting meetings,
how much money
they're asking for,
how much money they're getting.
We know how many female founders
there are, and that's great,
but doesn't really tell
us what the conversion is
on a lot of that.
So our goal and objective is to
really discover that and make
some changes around that.
Chicago was named the world
capital of female founders,
because we have so many of them.
So if that's the
case, I really believe
that we have a
lot of opportunity
here to not only start
investing in each other,
but seeing our companies grow,
become the most profitable
companies in the world.
So I would say my most
proud accomplishment,
if you will-- which
is always hard
for us, right-- was creating
a partnership with 1871.
So my company is
a vendor company
for 1871, which is a tech
incubator here in the city.
We provide the curriculum
and programming
for women-focused
accelerator program.
And we sent the first
company from 1871
to go into Y
Combinator this year.
So it was pretty
awesome to see that.
We don't provide
them any capital,
but we provide
them the resources
to connect them to community,
capital just in terms
of network and
technology resources.
Like Google for
Entrepreneurs has
been an amazing aspect of that.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Cool.
Thanks, Nicole.
I told you they're incredible.
So the common thread, I
think, across these five women
is they're clearly very
passionate about what they did,
and I think they took
initiative in driving
their careers forward.
In doing that, sometimes
you face obstacles.
So what's a challenge
that you faced?
What's the toughest
time in your career,
and how did you overcome that?
KATY EXLINE: Yeah, so the
biggest challenge for me
was in that initial
class that I took then.
I got that little spark
of, oh, this is cool.
I don't know what to do now,
but this class was great.
So the toughest challenge that
I faced-- which I'm lucky,
there are people who face
much worse than I did--
was just trying to
navigate the industry.
Because there are
so many buzzwords,
like rails, Django, docker.
Like, what?
And it was challenging
to try and figure out
some sort of path.
I wasn't even
trying to pick what
I was going to do, just a path.
And so what really helped me
overcome that obstacle was I
just jumped into something.
And so that's when I ended up
jumping not just into the Girl
Develop It class, but
then in the group.
And I met this network
of awesome women.
And we would just sit at a
coffee shop, and we would talk.
And it's amazing how those
little micro connections
start to snowball.
And that was how I learned
about the coding bootcamp,
and I actually, within one
of those coffee meetings,
had some validation
where somebody said,
yeah, you should do it.
Those types of words
make all the difference.
So really the toughest
challenge for me
was just figuring
these things out.
And I have just been so lucky
to have an awesome network
of people that just
continues to grow and expand
to help navigate that.
So that's my challenge.
RIANA LYNN: I would say
probably until maybe even a year
and a half ago, it was
hard for a lot of us to--
or I can't speak for you guys.
But I think there
might be a little bit
of understanding in this.
But my family and friends
really didn't understand a lot
about entrepreneurship, tech,
the pathway, as you said.
And so I worked at
the White House.
I was a researcher at Duke
since graduating in 2008
from undergrad.
And they're like, why would
you leave those opportunities?
My grandmother
still says today, I
would have still been over
at Duke or the White House.
But she's so proud of
me and now understands
where I can go with my
passion and with everything
that I'm doing.
And at first it was
really a challenge,
because mothers,
grandmothers, friends
don't see us in these roles.
They don't see a lot
of these stories.
They don't understand what
we would do on a day to day,
or how entrepreneurship
is changing,
how new ideas are
really impacting
all of our industries.
And so it took several years for
them to see that kind of payoff
and where it can go.
And so I'm excited now that
we have all these stories,
and they're talking
about it more in media.
But that was initially
the challenge.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: I would say
is a big challenge that I
faced throughout my career
and am still challenged by
is something called
impostor syndrome.
I'm sure a lot of
you have heard of it.
I left school after getting
my bachelor's degree.
And robotics is a
relatively new industry.
And most people have
gone to grad school.
Most have their PhDs, not
even just their master's.
And so I constantly
felt like, oh my gosh,
I'm in a room with all these
super bright people who
have done all this research.
What am I doing here?
Another thread
throughout my career
has been that I've changed
jobs a couple times,
and each time it hasn't
been the same exact thing.
I went from doing research,
to doing mass market,
to doing industrial work.
And so while I have eight years
of professional experience,
it feels every like
I make that switch
like I'm a total newbie at it.
And so just working
really, really hard
to get up to speed to be on
the same level as my peers
has-- I mean, I've
worked hard to do it,
and I feel like I belong.
But there's definitely
the nagging gremlins,
I call them, in my mind that
say, do you belong here?
Are you as good as your peers?
Things like that.
So I would ask anyone here who
has advice for how to get over
that to please see me after.
NICOLE YEARY: I
would say for myself
was to pull away from
this-- through school,
we're always given a
path and direction.
And we're told what
classes we need
to take to get to what
school we want to go to.
And then we go through
all those classes.
And then we graduate,
and we're told
we're going to get
a job in this area.
And then when that
doesn't happen,
then you have to become
creative, and start
becoming innovative
with your own skills,
and figuring out, how am I going
to actually make things work,
and not having a plan B.
That was really challenging
when the market did crash
and there wasn't a clear
path for me to go down.
And I even watched
this with my mom,
because I organized a women's
focus startup weekend,
and I invited her to join.
And day two she cried.
Because she's a
systems engineer,
so she's in technology,
always grew up
around servers and
her changing tapes.
But for the first
time, she was forced
to kind of think for herself
and not given direction,
and be creative with
what she does know,
and be confident about that.
And I think that the
greatest challenge for me
was really to learn how to
unwind what I had been taught
about following a path, a
direction that was the way we
were supposed to go, and to
develop a thought of my own,
and seeing a path that no one
else had highlighted for me.
BRENDA WILKERSON: Yeah, and I
pick up on that thread, too.
Because I think we all have
this sort of prescribed pathway
that starts out when
we're raised with parents.
They love us.
They're trying to help us.
We absorb some of
that direction.
But to really be able
to break out of it,
many times there's
those barriers
we always face where people
want you to kind of stay
in your place, whatever that is.
And I feel like
one of the things
that I found-- because I
was always entrepreneurial
growing up.
And being an entrepreneur and
thinking like an entrepreneur
has a very important
space in tech,
even if you aren't striking
out and creating your own.
And so the challenge for
me was to really balance
my creative side with the
traditional technical side
and figure out-- and
also the medical side.
Because I wanted to help
people to improve their lives.
And so coming through the
various tech jobs that I had,
there was sort of this struggle
with, OK, I can do this,
and I'm good at this.
But really, is this
what I want to do?
Is this really the investment
in people that I want to make?
And so really getting
into education-- balance
all those things to really
be able to figure out
how to help first adults and
now kids to find their place,
and to really find their voice,
and to work on that muscle of,
I think I can know what I
can do with the knowledge
that I'm being given.
And to learn to find their
own path to knowledge
is really where I found
that sweet spot for me.
But even in there
was a challenge,
because with the work that I'm
doing, it's very common now.
But in the beginning,
it was a vision.
And people laughed,
and people thought
it would never
happen, and to really
kind of go against the wind.
And one of the
ways I describe it
is pushing the peanut up
the hill with my nose,
and really finding that
inner strength to say,
even though people
don't agree with you,
or people don't
understand and don't
see your vision, that doesn't
mean that your vision is wrong.
And I think especially
as women, we
have to find that
inner strength.
And if you can find somebody
that believes in you,
that is great.
If you can't, then if
you know that that's
what you're supposed
to be doing,
you have to put your
feet down and say,
I know that this is right.
I believe this is what
I should be doing.
And when it breaks,
oh, it's great,
but to have the strength
to just kind of persevere.
KARISHMAH SHAH: That's a
nugget of wisdom-- confidence
in your vision and the
grit to make it a reality.
In navigating these
challenges, how important
do you think it is to
have one or many sponsors,
role models, mentors?
Have you gotten any amazing
career advice from one?
KATY EXLINE: I think
it's really interesting.
I have a lot of women
through Girl Develop It
who approach me and say,
I'm looking for a mentor.
And sometimes I just
want to say, look around.
And I think it is, traditionally
speaking, and speaking
along the lines, again,
of what should be done,
or what is traditionally
talked about,
is having a formal mentor.
And I think that environment
has changed a lot.
And I really found a lot of
value in the Ms. Tech group.
There's a resource
of women there.
And peers of mine
have been-- there
are some in the
crowd here that have
been wonderful mentors
to me, some that are
further along in their careers.
So I can't say that I've had one
particular person, because it's
doing a disservice to so many
of the people that have really
helped me.
And that's worked for me.
Some people may like to have
maybe one person that they
can kind of go to and lean on.
But don't feel
like you've failed
at finding a mentor if
you're leaning on a network.
Because it's worked.
BRENDA WILKERSON: And I think
that all across the range,
it's great to have that person
or those people to talk to.
Very rarely did I get that.
Early in tech, it
was kind of isolated.
There weren't a lot of women,
and sometimes even the culture
of being able to help
each other wasn't there.
But understand that there
are mentoring experiences.
This is a mentoring experience.
For me sitting here listening
to these wonderful stories,
I'm being mentored
by their pathway.
And so you find just
getting into conversations--
we need to talk.
We need to talk to each other.
We'll learn from each other.
But seeking out a mentor-- I
recently finally got a mentor.
I had been seeking her for
years when I thought, OK, it
wasn't happening naturally.
I found a woman within
CPS, and thought,
I'm really proud of her.
I know she's paved a lot of
the way for this type of work
that I'm doing.
And I started
knocking on her door.
And it took a year before
she had time to talk to me.
But I didn't give up.
I kept calling her.
I didn't bug her,
but I was persistent.
And finally we got there.
So be as persistent in seeking
out the things that you know
that you need, as
well as-- as women
we're always helping others.
And it will be amazing
how you will find help
in all different
types of experiences.
RIANA LYNN: Yeah, I
would agree that there
are great communities now.
I love the kind of
group interaction
I get from Ms. Tech
and other groups
here in Chicago and
across the country.
I'd be happy to share some
of these wonderful groups,
especially that are
highly active on Facebook.
But I tell people
this story a lot.
Early on, just right
after undergrad,
I was very passionate
and very confident
with seeking out my mentors.
And I think that you have
to just make that step
and do what you can to
get access to the people
that you think are
untouchable or unreachable.
I remember learning Photoshop
and the full Adobe suite,
building a website,
building out a media company
just to get press passes to
Obama's first inauguration, all
of these events that had
people that were leaders
from all over the world.
And I ended up at
this award ceremony
with some of the top
researchers and entrepreneurs
in the country.
And I walked up to
this guy who was just
featured on "60 Minutes"
as a top researcher
at the University of Chicago,
and also an entrepreneur,
and said, I want to
intern for you the summer.
Give me your card.
Let's make it happen.
And he never knew I was there
under this fake press pass.
But I told him later on, and
a great mentor to this day.
But I tell people, find a
way to work with the people
that you want to work with to
learn from them in whatever
capacity.
Do not be scared to go up
to them and get their card.
Don't give them your card.
Make sure you get their
card, because they probably
won't email you back, or they
will lose it in the shuffle.
And sometimes LinkedIn and
stuff is not that effective.
But no matter how
young you are, people
appreciate someone that's
passionate that can help them
even for free.
Luckily, he got a budget
for me to work for him.
But you even have to
seek the opportunity
to work on a night or weekend
to learn from these folks
and get right there
in the grit with them.
And it's just been
exciting to share that
with other folks that are
looking for mentorship,
and now also be a mentor myself.
JUSTINE REMBISZ:
I totally agree.
Advocating for
yourself is really
the key to getting mentorship.
I think it's great,
like some of you
were saying earlier,
finding groups of your peers
in the community
that you can talk to.
But then finding someone that
has a bit more experience
is also really, really valuable.
And something that
someone told me
when I was younger in my
career and looking for mentors
is, the worst they
can do is say no.
And that's really it.
It's not like they're going
to hate you for asking them
for some of their time.
You're going to be
denied a job at Google
because you asked me to mentor
you on how to do robotics.
So I'd really encourage everyone
to just put yourself out there
and just ask the question.
The worst that can
happen is they'll say no.
NICOLE YEARY: I think that using
every possible tool that you
have out there to
engage with people,
and also just with yourself
to tap into what you already
know-- books.
You can learn so much
from books, right?
Just one I will
share with you that I
find with the wisdom
group is called
"Monday Morning Leadership."
And it's eight
mentoring sessions,
and they're captured
in a very short read.
But doing that
together, the very first
lesson it talks about is being
a driver versus a passenger.
And as Riana mentioned,
you have to be that driver
and take ownership
for everything
that happens in your life.
So be it good or
bad, it's my fault,
and I take ownership for that.
So if I'm hungry enough,
I will go after it.
And I think that that's what
you see with others, too,
is if they're hungry, you
want to help them as well.
And just really tapping
into what Katy mentioned,
knowledge sharing,
for me, I think
is the most powerful
way of learning.
There is nothing better than
connecting with someone who's
going through the same
thing you're going through
and can tell you what they
know, save you some time,
and/or provide you just
really an ear to listen,
or even for you to
be the listener.
And that presence makes
such a huge difference
in your confidence
and your clarity.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Thanks.
Justine, I saw some bright
eyes when you mentioned
that no one would get denied a
job at Google if they asked you
about how to get into robotics.
So if they were to ask you,
how would you advise them?
JUSTINE REMBISZ: Sure.
So I would say at the young
college level, the three
industries that get
you into robotics
are software engineering,
mechanical engineering,
and electrical engineering.
Studying those in
school is important.
Beyond school, I
think there's ways
to get into robotics
through the maker community.
So Katy actually
introduced me to Adafruit
just a couple days ago.
But get an Arduino.
There's a ton of support
groups online for that.
In terms of mechanical and
electrical engineering,
a lot of the barrier to
entry is the design software.
But for mechanical
engineering, there's
something called
Onshape, which will let
you do mechanical CAD for free.
It's a cloud-based service.
And then for
electrical engineering,
Eagle is something that will
allow you to do schematics
and board design.
Instructables.com is great at
breaking down maker projects.
Go to maker fairs near you.
Get involved in that community.
Get in touch with those people.
Hackaday is another
great resource,
and I have a few more if you
want to talk to me after.
RIANA LYNN: And locally,
Catalyze Chicago
will soon be launching mHUB,
100,000 square feet of space
for makers.
They're looking to diversify
the space as much as possible.
It will be the 1871 of
manufacturing and makers,
so look out for those
announcements coming soon.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Cool.
So in designing a
career that you love,
designing a life that
you love around that,
do you ever burn out?
What do you do
when you burn out?
How do you balance living your
life and pursuing this passion?
Brenda, let's start with you.
BRENDA WILKERSON:
Burnout is a real thing.
It's a real thing.
And it's one of those
things that if you're
really passionate and you
really dig yourself in
and you start to work really
hard, it's hard to not at least
taste it a little bit.
I think one of the
things that I do
to balance burnout is to make
sure I remember my core belief
systems.
I am creative, so I find
something else to create.
I actually spent a
portion of my background
in creating knitted
outerwear, believe it or not.
And so I got back into knitting.
And as I'm knitting,
it's creative.
I'm able to sort of take
a break from the grind,
but then also work through
some of those things that
are on the back burner that
I want to work on next.
We're always multitasking.
We always have other ideas.
Some take the
forefront at a time,
but there's all
these other things
that are still being processed.
So I think when you approach
burnout, you back off
and you think about
some of those things,
and you give them
their attention.
I think as women,
it's very key for us
to remember to take
care of ourselves.
I think we inherently
are the caregivers,
the lovers of other
people and other things.
But it's amazing that
when you give yourself
a break-- my staff, I gave
myself 10 days around Christmas
where I just sat around.
And I didn't check my email.
I didn't do a thing.
I was shocked that I did that.
But when I came
back, I was on fire,
because I had powered down
the system for a minute.
So it's great to be successful
in what you're trying to do.
But give yourself a break.
And it will actually be the
fuel to help you be better
at what it is that you do.
KATY EXLINE: I was going to
say that exact same thing.
Take care of yourself.
I've come across it as a
Girl Develop It leader.
We actually, the Girl Develop It
chapter leaders across the US,
have a shared Slack channel.
And we have a channel
called Just Say No.
It's so hard, too, when you
have all these great ideas.
Oh, wouldn't it be
great to do a hackathon?
Or oh, I'd love to do
a robotics workshop.
And at some point
you have to say no.
Like no, I need a
Netflix and nails day.
So it's very hard, because
sometimes I felt the guilt of,
I should be doing this,
or I could be doing this,
or should be doing
this for my career.
And you have to
strip away all the
should haves, all what
you could be doing.
Just look at where
you are right now.
Take care of yourself mentally,
physically, professionally.
Take care of you, because you
are your biggest advocate.
So if you take care of
yourself, you will succeed.
Things will work out for
you, and just say no.
KARISHMAH SHAH: This
is like my recent steer
towards JOMO instead of FOMO.
So FOMO is Fear Of Missing Out.
But now I'm loving JOMO,
which is Joy Of Missing Out.
It's really just taking
that time for yourself.
Riana?
RIANA LYNN: I love the JOMO.
I would say sometimes
I try to take
little chunks of my day or week
to work on my mental health.
Because I can work for long
stretches of time, and even
at really crazy hours.
There's been times I've
posted on Ms. Tech group
at like 2:00 AM.
Nicole is also-- she'll
accept it at 3:00 AM.
Her schedule's
pretty crazy, too.
But I have a goal
of being-- I don't
know who holds this
title right now,
but I really want to be one
of the world's foremost fruit
experts.
So I just try to
discover as many fruits
around the world as possible
and just learn as much
about them as possible.
So travel is something that I
try to build into my career.
I have brought my MacBook
to so many crazy places,
and it kind of
scares me sometimes.
So we'll see how we can
work on some new safety
innovations around that.
But definitely travel, and
just finding a good hobby
that can give you that
mental break, maybe
something on the more
physical side to keep that up.
And what you learn,
too, is if you're
taking care of your mental
and physical health,
you're that much further
ahead of your competitors,
just because you are able to
come back with this energy
and really kind of push things
forward at an accelerated pace.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: Kind
of a weird response,
probably, but I got a dog.
And just the
responsibility of having
to be home at a certain time to
take care of my dog every day
actually allows me to shut
off and say, OK, now this
is the time that I need to
take care of this living thing
and put some energy into it.
And that gives me enough of a
mental break that usually then
I can continue with my own
self support type stuff,
like working out, or
cooking dinner for myself,
or something like that.
But a bit more
seriously, too, I'm
pretty fiercely protective
of my weekends as well.
I try not to email anyone
on my team on the weekends,
because then that gets
them into the mode of,
oh my god, she's expecting
me to respond back,
or anything like that.
So I try to shut off.
I mean, obviously
I kind of check
to make sure there's
no emergencies.
But I set it as
a goal for myself
to not send any email
out over the weekend.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Keep
it in that draft box.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: Yeah, exactly.
NICOLE YEARY: I've been
thinking about a puppy
for that same reason.
It will force me to go home.
I think that the most important
thing that I've reminded myself
is that you're the
only one who can
define what your balance is.
So if I'm up at 3:00 in the
morning, and I'm OK with that,
and I'm still being mindful
of my sleep, my nutrition,
and making sure that I take
care and balance in my own way,
I do what I have to do.
Because at the end
of the day, I'm
the only one who's
going to do everything
that I need to do
by the deadlines
I need to get them done by.
So be your own
definition of balance.
And for me, that is every day
I know I need to walk home,
and I need to have
my music in my ears,
and I need to be alone.
I don't want anybody
else walking with me.
I have a 17 minute
walk, and I love it.
I look forward to it every day.
The other things I do is I will
shut all the lights off, put
candles on, aroma therapy,
take a hot bubble bath.
Whatever I can do
to just really--
I'm aware of what helps
me unwind mentally.
And so as long as you know
what that is for yourself,
I think that's the
most important.
KARISHMAH SHAH: I love it.
So we had some great discussions
about the future of technology.
So talk to us about the future.
What are you most looking
forward to in technology?
Brenda, go ahead and share.
BRENDA WILKERSON: I'm really
looking forward to the world
that we're creating
where little kids get
to learn to think and create.
And we're giving people--
at a very young age,
it's going to be normal for
them to be able to solve
their own problems.
They have the tools.
That just really turns me on.
And normally I have
this great imagination.
I can say, here's what
that's going to look like.
I have no idea what
Because it's so new for people
to get that kind of power.
But I'm so excited
for it, people
to be able to solve problems
and have the confidence that it
takes to do whatever they
want to do in their lives
because they know how
to do these things.
So I'm really turned on by that.
KARISHMAH SHAH:
Empowering people
with the skill of
computer science.
BRENDA WILKERSON:
Yes, that's right.
KATY EXLINE: It's
just so cool, I'm
so excited about where education
is going at all levels-- what
you're doing with children.
And you know what,
I think Girl Develop
It, RailsBridge, [INAUDIBLE],
Women Who Code, these groups
are breaking down barriers
to learning about technology,
speaking about technology,
and that type of thing.
There's just so many pathways.
And we spoke about this earlier.
There was traditionally
this one path,
that you took computer science
and you got your master's
degree and whatnot.
And that is still an OK path,
but that's not the only path
anymore.
And that's particularly good
for women, or people of color,
or people who maybe
don't have the resources
or the privilege to be able
to take that traditional path.
So I'm just so excited about
where education is going
and how you can really
make education work for you
and your abilities and for
the resources you have.
RIANA LYNN: I would agree.
I always think to
myself that for me,
one of the most impactful things
of my past has been exposure.
And from that, I always
said that exposure is
the world's greatest professor.
And so when I think
of times that I've
traveled to other
countries, when
I think about the capacity
in learning that things
like Facebook have brought to
people, the digital exposure,
it's really great
to see how there
is a woman tech summit,
the Google Summit in Lagos
right now.
And so it's so exciting to
see how 10, 20 years ago,
a lot of people were talking
about illiteracy and reading.
But I feel like technology
has accelerated that problem
and brought so many
kids across the world
to more equality, more parity.
And I think technology and
the future of education
and technology is so promising.
And also just for
the future of tech,
I'm really excited about virtual
reality and augmented reality.
I think, from a summit I went
to at South by Southwest,
there's so much that we can
do, not just with gaming
or virtual reality
headset and sports,
but bringing people to
places they never thought
they would see in the world.
And so I'm excited for
the future of that.
KARISHMAH SHAH: What's the
future of agritech look like?
What's the future of agritech
look like, food and tech?
RIANA LYNN: You know,
there are many countries
that 80% of their economy
is based on agriculture,
and a lot of small
sustaining farmers
that are just working to grow
things just for their family.
And I think we've had so much
waste within food in agritech.
We have a world full
of hungry people,
but we grow enough food to
feed everybody in this world.
And I think we will see hunger
eradicated in our lifetime
if we just execute some of the
things in food and agritech
right, things that we didn't
really think we could solve 10,
15 years ago.
But to know that the average
American wastes 30% to 45%
of every food item
that they either touch
or that is grown in
their local area,
and to know that we can
reroute that in many ways--
not from growing better things
or creating new technology that
can grow more sustainably,
but creating tech systems that
can make sure that the
food gets to the right
places in the right time.
It's really exciting
to see that those two
worlds can come together
and solve those issues.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Absolutely--
big operations challenge.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: From
the robotics and hardware
perspective, I'm really excited
about ubiquitous robots in day
to day life.
I feel like we're really on
the cusp of mobile robotics
being a service to
people day to day.
We have the Roomba.
We have washing machines right
now, which I consider robots.
But I think really within
the next five years,
we're going to be seeing
self-driving cars.
We're going to be seeing drones
that are delivering things.
We're going to be
seeing robots that
do agriculture, just a lot more
service from that industry.
And I also think we're going
to see a lot more platforms
developed through these robots
that'll allow the children that
are learning about
computer science
right now to have
things to develop on.
And so I'm really excited
about both of those things.
NICOLE YEARY: I would say
there's a couple things that
keep me up at night,
and one of them
is that we need to help the
women here in this country
first to reach gender parity
before we can actually
go out and make changes
in other countries.
We are not at gender parity now.
And so now that
we have platforms
for funding and the
ability to make investments
in other women-founded
companies or products,
we should be doing
that more, and being
cognizant of where we're
actually putting our dollars.
I'm excited for the
future and opportunities
that I hope to build
with other people
and to create in terms
of funds for women.
There can't be enough right now
in terms of high growth tech
startups.
We don't have enough women.
I mean, how many
unicorns are there?
I think Danielle Morrill is
one of my favorites in terms
of just women that are
really killing it out there.
But we have a great
opportunity with college women.
And one thing that
we're doing at Ms. Tech
is we're creating
college collectives.
And it was thanks to
one of the interns
that we had-- the very
first intern I had.
Her name was Sanam Chakraborty,
and Oswin Chackochan, the two
women, they became
co-presidents down at Purdue.
And their bringing together
the worlds of business school
and technology.
Because those two schools
don't really communicate.
So how does innovation happen,
and how do they actually
build and create companies?
And they're working on a
startup right now called
Skaled, which has got "kale" in
it, because they're aquaponics
and vertical farming, and
getting rid of the whole food
desert idea.
So I think that if we look at
college women and being mentors
to them, or at least
encouraging them to not leave
the Midwest-- is
the big thing, too.
Two of the seniors
in the group--
right now we have 16 women.
And two of them, they're
both going to San Francisco.
So I'd really like to see
that we help really seed start
companies here and encourage
them to find careers here
in the Midwest, as well.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Love
it-- encouragement.
Let's all encourage each other.
We're right on time.
We're going to wrap
with one last question.
Rapid fire round-- what is
the single word that you think
characterizes the
attitude that you've
taken towards your career?
And whoever's got
it first can start.
NICOLE YEARY: Share.
KARISHMAH SHAH: What is it?
KARISHMAH SHAH: Share.
JUSTINE REMBISZ: Grow.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Grow.
RIANA LYNN: Evolve.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Evolve.
BRENDA WILKERSON: Vision.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Vision.
KATY EXLINE: Joy.
KARISHMAH SHAH: Joy.
And with that, can we thank
this fabulous panel of women?
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]